five minutes standard let's try see for
English time english but my opponent is
pretty much saying you know what we're
going to go into Queens gambit declined
accepted benoni c5 d5 okay an invitation
for maybe an Enzo hmm let's go with this
I don't want to commit my night just yet
get my bishop on g3 okay now what are we
going to have here just d5 grab some
space all right I'm going to look for
eventually getting my pawn all the way
up here that's going to be my plan
Bishop here right here and i wonder if i
should go night here so this is
interesting my opponent is ready to take
on d5 and after the recapture has this
advanced but i think i could somehow be
annoying with getting my bishop here and
then maybe I could be doing a push or
maybe not let me let me just let me do
this move I'm anticipating just this
structural change of Ed CD and then this
is is the normal reaction a4 to prevent
the queenside expansion so Knight c3
Bishop g2 of course I'm not sure where I
want to go with my king Knight f3 or do
I want to first play my pawn up to e4
maybe maybe I could do something like f
for this seems very odd play here for
one thing with some temp on the Queen I
think she's just misplaced I don't
understand the Queen's um I don't
understand that decision to play the
Queen to c7 seems like she's just asking
for some trouble like one thing I think
I could maybe be considering is just the
recapturing on this square with the
night and then recapturing with the
Queen hmm i think my queen would
eventually get kicked away with Bishop
to e6 I'm not so sure I accomplished
much but maybe I have something with
Bishop g5 and then if there's a capture
maybe I could take the night and then
recapture on d5 and it's much more
effective because the night is there
with tempo and
pretty much there to stay I better get
on this diagonal quickly so what's
what's happening here I have a space
advantage as soon as I played that d5
move on I've established that so I'm not
so inclined to be trading pieces since I
have more freedom to move about Bishop
f4 seems like it's not too far away from
happening here I'm assuming that okay
what's this night going to do right now
he's paralyzed and maybe a better
question is what is my opponent do if i
play f4 I think f4 means that my
opponent needs to play a five and then I
could play f5 and grab even more space
and I think I'm controlling the whole
position in the center space advantage
the Queen side and the King side after F
for my opponent doesn't make this move
I'm just going to steamroll me gaining
tempos maybe Forks further pushes
hitting the Queen the bishop so I'm
pretty sure f4 is the correct move here
and after a five I play f5 and my
opponent is really struggling to find
squares for pieces so is there something
better such as Knight f3 takes and then
this advanced oh there might be
something to that I think there is maybe
night here keep this tension for just a
moment if captures then I push Bishop
takes Queen a to pin it can be defended
with d6 but then I recapture and then
I'm winning
think I'm going to develop
I think this works if he takes f i have
e 5 okay now i'm pretty sure i do what
exactly no i think i actually want to
keep this tension I don't want to yeah
I'm going to keep this tension and now
i'm going to be even faster to getting
this 'if I've advanced in so I'm going
to keep my opponent guessing I don't
want to commit just yet i think this is
this is a situation where keeping the
tension is going to be more beneficial
to me i know that my opponent can't take
me but my opponent I have to there they
have to keep guessing am I going to take
or am I going to push forward I'm not
showing my hand and because of that they
have to be prepared for two different
pawn structures one that's completely
closed with f5 and then one where I'm
just smashing everything open and I
think the Queen maybe even runs the risk
of getting trapped I could consider just
capturing very soon a couple times and
then following up with Bishop f4 and
then pushing this night around this is
this is a difficult very very difficult
position for black okay that is one rule
that I did not consider I'm very tempted
to just play here and try and squeeze
black but this seems very appealing as
well to just open the position up get
the bishop pair my bishop on f4 kick
this night away I'm going to go with
that let's go with this
Bishop f4 to follow my probably not
going to take okay Queen St drop back
now I have this advance where's that
night going to go just want to complete
my development 'if I've kicked the night
away first and then castle a minute 42 a
minute 30 get this night away if he goes
here he gets trapped no he doesn't go
here next is he really bothering me
let's just get him out of there let's
get him out of there you guys should do
this this is Oh what's going on with
that my opponent didn't react to the
threat you're just getting ahead of
themselves okay this is oh I shouldn't
have done that I'm getting my opponents
getting a piece back oh yeah it's gonna
get hit okay well let's go with this I
get that pawn back oh that was so bad ok
this is still good i'm pretty sure
pretty sure it's still good i want to
take that night out and then just take
this pawn i was up a piece i gave the
piece right back they're giving me a
piece right back what is going on what
is going on now everything is falling
what is going on here ok let's just lock
everything up this is going to be a good
home for my bishop I have my rook here
to defend the second it's easy to go
into pre move mode here everything is
defended the night
jumps in here and we look to just push
the pond to d8 nothing to do 25 seconds
with tempo the night comes here keep
pushing keep pushing take this pawn the
king is constrained rip 2d to push just
stop rook here stuff
alright let's just sneak over here and
then control da should do it no time
either no steal me pompeu ish followed
by rook on the back rent and that'd be
it alright no time good game that was
weird very weird let's I was ready to
just close out of that let's go back
flip this board what's the story here
from your perspective benoni I guess you
could still play a 6 here but I'm a
little worried after Queen c7 and then
even more worried after the bishop
decides to go on this this dog and I
don't know that this is a the best place
for in fact in the butt in the vanilla
this Bishop is the one at least one of
the pieces that struggles to do
something but turn out to be much worse
because this is this is a big trouble in
very big trouble can't do that can't
obstruct your central pawn I'm pretty
sure you have to go forward with
exchanging right here i think a 6 is
still fine but after a four I think you
do best to just capture after I
recaptured to go forward with the more
standard stuff such as d6 with the fiend
cuddling of the king getting a rook on
the e-file getting your bishop maybe to
g4 and f5 he's expendable if you could
give them up for a night that's often
still a good thing in this semi close
position with night d7 to maybe e5 to
follow ideally you'd like to get in b5
but that's that's going to take some
work but I'm thinking just take right
here just some standard stuff out of
this opening you takes DC takes D with D
6 g6 Bishop e7 castle rook e8 Bishop f5
g4 with connecting your nights
that's really my main suggestion because
after after this it's just too much I
have too much space too many good
decisions too many good options so and I
shouldn't have given back the piece
there of course what should I have done
here I could have just not taken here or
I guess I could take with the bishop and
then back up if the rook comes over here
either way it's it's just good for white
and nearly and pretty much every
variation so that's my suggestion out of
the gates out of the opening there but
the decisions with the ponds and the
captures and when if if you're the side
who's playing is white keep in mind the
the benefits of having this tension
maintained you're going to push and I
going to push am I going to capture keep
your opponent guessing already good game
let me close out